what's up everybody welcome back to
gamespot cross kind of funny here on
gamespot.com / III i'm greg that's
calling that it's quick lissitzky it's
so good to see you trap me thank you for
coming to lounging on our furniture make
order is rather comfy actually lay down
Nick you did a really good job with
these cows are giving yourself a hard
time yeah well it's just mean like blood
washes off easily so it does yeah I'm
gonna pull Dexter oh sorry it's may be
that kind of show there's the reason
you'll never see jeff course McHenry
thank you thank you oh this is an
amazing set up you guys are crushing it
yeah yeah but you were here last time
you were on our GDC stream yeah when
we're in patreon office nothing was
going right but we were trying man we
never have anything to talk about we
just got to sit around awkwardly stared
each other yeah yeah I know if only any
of us were good at just bullshitting I'd
almost is it for friends so we just get
to lands an art form or something yeah
yeah so what is new what's happening in
bosque how huge are you now we're at 40
damn yeah we got 40 people in the office
right there we took over the floor above
us in our building and we're still you
know 40 for a triple a studio still
pretty small yeah and I've said it
before I say it again I want to keep the
studio lean and mean I want to know
everybody's name preferably their
spouses name but we're at the point now
where we're targeting kind of a late
summer ish type of potential announced
what guy loves you hey you love you too
so are you late summer what what the
thing is man is I go to work on Monday
and I'm like I'm Isis game gonna work
it's just came gonna be fun and when we
hit midweek about wednesday thursday
friday i'm striving home like we got you
know it's it's what i'm making I can't
go to too much detail yet yeah it's a
very tangible game and I was having a
great conversation Dean Hall you know
yeah I'm desi and he's like well how
streamable zar game going to be I'm like
I'm hoping pretty freakin much yeah
because the saying I've always said it's
to your game is only as good as how many
YouTube videos that could yell and the
way we're building the game right now is
it so skill-based that there are certain
moves that I pull off in the game in the
year that the studio has been open I've
only done once or twice what I know
there's gonna be people out there that
are that good and that's skilled that
they're just gonna crush them
pull these moment these moments off
essentially make highlight reels like
you know NFL or NBA so what is the
elevator pitch for somebody's just
stumbling into this game spots dream
don't know what is the game well so i
worked in epic obviously for years they
do in new gears looks fantastic but i
started a new studio called bosque
productions yeah and we're doing a pc
free-to-play shooter that's sci-fi we've
been slowly but surely kind of leaking
some of the artwork from it and it's one
of those things that it's gonna be very
scale based and i don't want to be
sleazy free-to-play i want it to be good
free to play yeah the kind of game where
you're like no I like this community I
like this product I like the team behind
it shut up and take my money as opposed
to feeling like I'm reaching your wallet
kind of sneakily taking it out sure
which is unfortunately how it feels like
a lot of the mobile games so my goal for
our Jan by coo and I our gen came from
the kill zone backdrop as far as doing
all those PlayStation games I did the
gears games we want fans of traditional
shooters to see this and say you know I
don't normally play free to play but I'm
gonna give that a go and hopefully enjoy
it and crush it so that I mean for you
it's skill-based the shooter where does
the free-to-play not the micro
transactions in a bad way where does it
come in where you want people giving you
money well I mean we don't want you can
tell don't want everybody to necessarily
have to give us money that's the thing
is if you and I usually I use a lot of
metaphors about like restaurants and
bars and relationships we're creating
the pub if you want to come into the pub
and have a glass of water with a friend
probably not in California cos there's
no water i have a meeting you know
people sit at starbucks all day long on
their laptops they maybe not even buy
coffee but you know if you want you know
want a burger or pine to whatever it's
there so we're offering the venue of the
game that has this great experience with
a lot of great verbs yeah and then
hopefully people like hey you know what
I kind of like this game I'm gonna
support it with my dollars and what
we're doing is initially targeting some
of the cosmetics as far as you know how
can I have that spiffy red tie oh you go
to kind of other / red shoes exactly
like how can i do that to actually
volunteer to take the mic and hear me
out you all right production assistants
after completely repeat everything that
is rented out the rest of their even
know your purse so I know you haven't
were yelling in my ear if you couldn't
hear no absolutely I got good so I know
you're obviously you're making the game
on PC are you are is there any interest
in going back to console with their
there's always console interest that's
like the number one question that people
ask me and if Sony or and or Microsoft
were to come out to us too
be like let's do this I'd be like I'm
not gonna rule it out like why would I
why would I rule it out but the thing
about pc is we're really leveraging what
the keyboard and the mouse can do as far
as like the controls of the game and it
being very skill-based if this game is
porter to consoles it will be a very
tricky thing to pull off that it partner
like Sony or Microsoft will have to do
so it's possible I would want to do it
myself now you're talking to the guy who
got borderlands on the Vita yes I am I
got gone home kind of onto a console but
then the company book yeah I want me to
throw some tweets out there yeah could
you could you hook it up a little bit
I'm gonna build the list right now we're
gonna build the hashtag building a list
all right all right you drive for two
sec okay no I'll tell you the thing
about what we're doing over so the
keyboard the mouse is so strong that the
pacing alone it's going to be really
really tricky what is good oh well you I
can't lead in such a social media [ __ ]
now he's unbelievable all over it well
yeah I mean so we got 40 right now we
actually have some interns in the office
who doing a fantastic job and it feels
good you know the studio has a really
good company culture you know everybody
gets along you know we're already
engaging we do with live streams every
couple weeks you know we haven't we have
a decent following on there and put a
little number one thing that gamers
always say to me they just show me the
freaking game yeah they want to see the
damn game they're so tired of seeing my
big fat head flapping my gums they want
to see the game so how far off are you
we're targeting uh when the weather's
still warm for people to be able to see
something nice nice so could be one of
the great things I respect about you so
much is that you're a student of the
industry you understand it I love
hearing you talk about it you're a good
insight what you think about the press
conferences yeah look I see both sides
of it i like the hype i enjoy the hype I
couldn't watch some of them because I
was on a plane flying out here about
Microsoft's was fantastic sony
apparently made everybody's head explode
which mean like the final fantasy
remaking all of that the biggest thing
that blows my mind the trend that I'm
seeing is people being drunk on
nostalgia like it's the same thing when
you know they did the the video game
awards and Kenan Roberta Williams came
out announce a new King's Quest trended
worldwide on Twitter everybody just lost
their brains so it's like I Love New
Worlds i love new IP you know that yarn
game that was screaming
yeah unravel you know PR I just got to
see the latest oculus stuff and it's
just like mind blown it's absolutely
amazing so when people I got it's an HD
remake I'm like yeah fine that's cool
but show me new [ __ ] I just want to see
new [ __ ] yeah and then that's what I'm
doing with our new studios making it
yeah but everything is old is new again
right everybody every claiming for these
remastered every tengo rear mass every
10 to 15 years you get a remastered you
get a rematch you got a remaster
non-stop man what do you think about the
the gears remaster I mean I that's
coming out against this fall yeah well I
mean I was pretty much the worst kept
secret in the world um so give me Gears
of War one with 60 frames a second and
shiny roads sure I'll play the [ __ ] out
of that you know like I always thought
like I saw the future back when I was an
epic as far as the frame rate of
first-person shooters and that with
fighting games that started it had to be
60 and then with driving games force on
all that had to be 60 I'm like this is
coming with shooters call 2d broke the
mold 60 every game has to be 60 down
like as much as i enjoy destiny the
frame rate of Destiny not fully being at
60 actually impacted my some of my
enjoyment to it to a small extent i need
that frame rate do you you're one of
these frame rates guys do well my online
or not the framework I i am a margin my
COO and I he is a frame rate not like if
the game drops below 30 he screams and
breaks his keyboard and we just want to
have that just high-end experience right
well with shoot with shirt is especially
skill-based which shooters which is what
your seems like you're making that's
going to be essential well dude I mean
that's the thing is like I personally
working on the gears franchise over the
later years was dumb to the games down a
little bit Oh hit the button to look
over there and you're worried it's gonna
be too hard too hard too hard it's like
dude gamers want a challenge they want
something that's skill based they want
something I mean ice the one game i
still play the most right now csgo like
counter-strike is still the most
airtight shooter I played in years and I
we just play like the 10 v10 in the pubs
and the kids are still amazing in that
game these people have been playing this
game for 15 years like and once you get
that off like it's it's sink or swim in
your own volition that gave us so much
respect for that game and that's kind of
the skill level that we're targeting for
this game yeah I mean is that why you're
playing or is it just because it's so
speaks to you is it the best in the biz
it's shooting if you guys everything's
it's it's still the best shooter the
game type is so airtight the stakes are
high you know one shot you're basically
dead essentially right your headshot
right you know you're buying all the
different weapons to the weapons skin
mechanics they put that gamer absolutely
brilliant that's an example of you know
it's the others to keep a gain of like
fourteen dollars to get in but they
monetize that game in a very cool unique
way that whenever I get that crate I'm
like 250 250 right and I'm actually
excited about it so that's one of the
good examples such as you know league or
tota or these other games that do a
free-to-play model and they don't do it
like a sleazy Las Vegas 5 yeah was there
a big learning curve for you I mean
going from making gears doing this to
now getting out there and having I mean
free to place all around right but I
don't I wouldn't consider myself an
expert on anybody who's an expert
doesn't share their data because it's
like oh we're not going to share our
secret sauce with you and we're going to
tell you exactly what makes World of
Tanks work right thing I've learned
about free to play that I've learned
about relationships personal
professional all that every single one
is unique what works in one free to play
game might not work in another you look
at the ecosystem of dota of League and
then you know team fortress 2 all these
core games that are free to play the
handle monetization in different ways in
many different ways so that's the thing
as we work through the game with the
community we're gonna figure out what's
a good non sleazy way to monetize the
game are you you know you're working on
the free-to-play game it seems like a
smart venture for you do you feel a lot
of pressure to deliver considering
you're a name and there are expectations
with what you're I mean I'm a name but
the effort I always say the average 14
year old who's watching YouTube videos
to PewDiePie doesn't know who I am
doesn't give a [ __ ] who I am and now
justice and that's only gonna that that
that cachet only goes so far so you know
decent Twitter followers aside that's
cool that helps they still want to see
the game so there's pressure there the
fact you know a lot of the fans with my
previous work only know me from the
console side of things yeah they forget
the fact that i had a 386 sx that i did
jazz jackrabbit on back in the day and
then even an apple to see before that
the fact that me know the pcu is my
roots and being back on pc feels good
and it's one of those things that you
know we'll see where it goes it's gonna
go to playstation we tweeted them is
john drake is just mean bugging me over
there
now so yeah the back is turned now we
can just scream for Gio Corsi over and
over again until he comes so I mean this
is kind of a full circle thing for you
so do you do you feel like they're still
even though the consoles are selling
well is that a place you want to be is
that still a viable future 10 years down
the road or you really feel like things
will you to fire go to play again I've
been in this business a while I look at
all this and I'm like I things like
packs excite me more like pax's III to
be fair let some gamers in this year
finally ram and it go through the crazy
hoops of getting a press badge and
showing a business card all that stuff
but this to me all I see when I look
around here is the spend of money to
impress walmart and target yeah where my
brain is already all digital like I'm
thinking steam or whatever platform is
all digital how can this game be on that
so when I look around here as much as I
like the hype and I see hey look there's
you know you know the new IP from Sony
excited like that's cool but I just see
how much that screen cost how much that
setup costs so much that booth cost
Union yeah just this square cost right
just right then Phil Spencer just one
right by to like summoning summoning
that's the Sony and Microsoft folks
right now that's the weird disconnect I
guess even maybe it's the meeting place
of the industry right we're all right
you know creators or artists and they
love what they do they put they work at
dark rooms and then they come here in as
well people they try and act like making
software making video games it's all
exciting yeah it's like now we're
sitting in a computer all day long or we
have a meeting yeah that's it like this
is when we get to get out but you know
the beauty of these shows apart from the
jokes about the money and everything is
I get to run into people I've known for
10 15 20 years now ya know and like are
you bed and then everyone wants to know
how the studio's going you know what the
culture is like when we're gonna show
the damn game and I mean this is this is
my blood I thought I would quit but now
i can't i can't leave this business
you're like Ric Flair you're gonna
retire like 15 my North Carolina whoa
whoa Rick's the man so it's it you know
i just love video games man the weird
thing right now though is like i said
the only thing really excites me is
counter-strike go like everything else
for some strange reason is boring me and
I don't know if the problem is me or not
like I love Dorian the blind forest
right
played axiom verge a bunch that was
great but a lot of the games right now
I'm just kinda I'm like oh yeah you know
I just what about the announcements and
stuff from this this fallen for do
anything for you know I play the [ __ ]
out of fallout 3 i'll play fallout 4 i
was hoping for a new Elder Scrolls also
because I love fall out but I prefer a
bit of you know for the skyrim type
games you have that MMO now on consoles
there you go yeah thank you you're well
but here's the thing about follows fall
when you play the last fall out it was
actually kind of emotionally exhausting
yeah because the world was Saudi
saturated if you look at the new one
they've actually loud a little a little
bit more color to actually finally bleed
black back through in it it's like if
you ever play a multiplayer game that's
all dark and rainy you kind of get
seasonal affective disorder yeah you
kind of like man it's kind of bummed I
feel I feel I feel depressed I don't
know why there's a reason why the
majority of halo maps are like well lit
because that's the environment you're
literally teluk teleporting yourself in
24 hours on end sure surely you know I'm
curious you know you talk about you know
you can never leave the industry you
know clearly you've thought about it
what would you like what are your other
interest what would you want to do if
you left like would you want to use W
obviously you have such a creative gene
in you I mean I love intellectual
property of world creation I mean maybe
something involving screenwriting or
film or something like that um but other
than that like I wouldn't you know I
enjoyed my year and a half off but it
was honestly like I was done like six
months out I was like no let's start
negotiating for deal let's talk to
various interested parties to talk about
actually starting a studio so that's how
long I lasted yeah you could put yeah
just ahead it's like even jason rubin
over an oculus cuz Jason was you know
Naughty Dog for years yeah he took like
a some time off he's like I got to get
back into this this is getting way too
interesting now so the thing is is you
know we're building this game we're
going to establish it but long-term I
want to really take a good long look at
vr really yeah like if you guys have a
chance to get hands on with like so when
we were at GDC the the five just
completely blew my brain it was
absolutely a religious experience the
latest oculus stuff it's on that level
it's pretty damn magical when you look
down you actually see your hands then
you see somebody standing across from
you it's pretty impressive stuff yeah do
you think there's going to be commercial
challenges for VR because it's so hard
to show someone unless they just put it
on that's it well that's the thing it's
like you talk about you know Walmart
target it's like all you need is a kiosk
in the mall and you put somebody into it
and insert the matrix jokes yeah really
know what PR is you have to see it for
yourself and everybody you see that I
usually there's two types of people
right those who have experienced VR and
believe in it and those who still doubt
it right yes I especially I understand
doubting oculus one point 0 even the dk2
but when you get to the point where the
latest Crescent Bay you look at the five
like you cannot fight it and you know
I've said on social it's like you know
if I can home you know I put on my damn
spandex shorts and take my helmet I go
for a bike ride and then I have to
shower after that and that's that's like
a lot of steps I gotta fill up my water
bottle get my strava am going all the
stuff right right like pr's half that
and you get this amazing experience
where you could just fly up Everest in
fewer or be at the bottom of the ocean
and without any risk at all that was the
thing for my first oculus demo you know
they gave it to me they put it on I mean
that I was in the room like the cave
there's the guy in the throw there's the
volcano is like right now we're gonna
take you out sounds like Aris is cool
he's like now woke up and I look up and
I flew yeah and I was like oh [ __ ] yep
you don't I mean cuz that's what excites
me is like not even a game game but as
much as like b6 and export of Metropolis
it's the experience and so I'm sitting
here with a fellow sitting here are the
literally Palmer's in front of me
virtually instructing me to go through
it and I pick up to these big toy hands
yeah I have what are essentially Hulk
fists yeah er I'm like yes right yeah
I've been waiting for and then I
actually picked up a ball and I throw a
hip homer in the head and then there's a
tetherball we're heading back it was
just it was pretty magical ya know it's
those little experience you always talk
about when you eat Valerie I'm calling
it operation awesome total religious
experience is exactly what it was
because I was like I'm a core gamer I
don't wanna play OVR then I went to
CCP's booth you know two or three years
ago wait it wasn't the dk2 yeah what so
it wasn't even where it is now yeah and
the game certainly was is what is done
that screen door effect exactly but I
put it on and it won't you know our old
friend Ryan that we worked with the
proper throttle and those no no it was
it was all it was like it was like a
very like loose like five minute MOJ
zone where you got in it what you're
talking about like this is a game
changer whereas this one was you looked
on you were like paralyzed yeah it was
troll be but even then it was in my 93
it was the only ever demo I was like I
want to play that again right now did
you dream about it yeah I
right no iPad I've had like be our
dreams yeah after experiencing some of
the pr that I have and I I will be an
ardent defender of it on social media
until the cows come home yes always some
cynical dude going I don't buy it it's
like dude not just for gaming right like
you're not gonna play team fortress on
this that was a bad idea putting team
fortress on it but the kind of games you
know missed exploration games you know
just virtual tourism you know that's the
thing like blows my mind is yeah travel
for people who've never been out of
their home much you know it goes back to
that classic viral video that oculus had
of the older lady looking at the Tuscany
demo right and you know she she got to
go to Tuscany you know like PTSD
treatment like there's so many different
things right that it could be used for
it's it's a real game-changer yeah I do
and I do believe that it is one of those
I I believe that there's some people out
that I've tried it in stop for them but
i do believe most people out there they
just tried it they would believe in it
because I certainly did you know and it
seems like a lot of even the early one
right like i said the early one yeah i
had issues and there might honestly be
ten percent of the population they can
never solve the sickness thing with ya
you know dude you fly and there's
there's always you know the vomit bags
in the airplane yeah it just gets a glow
like that happens right so I mean the
experience of going to another place you
know and previously with the valve stuff
was the most impressive stuff I've seen
oculus has stepped up their game yeah so
I feel like these are real places I've
been to in my brain which is just weird
right yeah you know immensity eventually
gonna get the haptics toots and it's
going to be ready [ __ ] player one well
that was the thing of like the hololens
demo right if I still haven't seen that
yet it's really cool it'll still over
there I might need to pull some strings
for the Halloween soon can we get him to
see how Owens mr. Spencer please do you
want to come up you want to talk about
Holland know what was cool about it is
like it started with them staring at man
staring at the wall and it was project
on the wall and I was like all right and
then when he went to the table and
looked at the table and it went up I was
like that's why i said i think that
stole the show ya know that was like
yeah that was the moment for me rounds
like oh my god that looks I think
Microsoft is partner to some extent with
oculus for some of the stuff because I
think Microsoft recognizes that virtual
reality and augmented reality are
drastically different things ya know the
the the big dark horse in this race is
magically I haven't seen anything from
magically you know I've been talking to
the buckling down to Florida and
visiting to actually check it out it's
supposed to be pretty
freaking impressive yeah so we'll see
what do you think about morpheus
morpheus I'm actually believing I think
Morpheus has a really good shot at being
the first vr that's really for consumers
that they can easily set up yeah cuz
it's a fixed platform right they got the
controller's right did you do the London
heist no I haven't been the heist I was
on look down and you pick up the gun and
you load the magazine into the gun
you're like okay this is cool yeah if
you like you're in some sort of like
interactive guy ritchie film yeah it's
really for that was like yeah when i did
the first time i ever did was the deep
where you're in the shark tank yep and
when that they're like you can move and
like you moved this and this was one I
was like oh yeah alright cool like that
demo itself was enough for me to be like
I buy it for this but yeah the
implications of what that could mean
that got super exciting that's the thing
is you know like there's multiple horses
in the race now this is a bit for
everybody yeah you know my good friends
at oculus I was like you know the
Facebook acquisition I'm like don't get
lazy guys yeah you know and I run a blog
post about it's like I still want PR
forget about you know the games the
company investment all that [ __ ] I as
like as a nerd I want my VR and I want
you know and I will dedicate a room in
my home for VR yeah and you know and it
doesn't necessarily always have to be
the 15 by 15 foot space yeah it's there
could be people just do the seated thing
people just do the standard things
standing up thing or they could do the
full 15 by 15 you know it's like
watching a movie on your phone yeah or
watching it in the hotel room or
watching at your friend's theater right
like it anything in between so I just
I'm really excited about all the
possibilities man the fact I i know i'm
i'm down on it in the way of I think
sometimes it's being marketed on wheat
you know Colin and I are PlayStation
pundits a lot so I had a lot to say
about how more fees is coming along but
the fact that everyone's getting on
board with it and doing something makes
me think it's actually has a shot it's
not free d I think the biggest enemy of
VR is people having a crappy first VR
experience right it's you know and you
know as much as I think the google
cardboard is cute and cool and you know
even the oculus with the phone in your
face right yeah a lot of people are
doing right now I'm worried about the
hype train I'm worried about your
average person your muggles putting it
on and getting sick and saying I tried
that VR once it didn't work that's my
biggest concern is somebody who wants VR
to actually happen what they need to do
is replicate basically the week whether
we got into every house because of nerds
like us and then your mom played age
like oh I could do this yeah
is cooler than they need the hook as
well yeah we only need a lot of games
that not just have trouble where a
drastic thing we'd always talk about
when you're trying to reach like a
casual audience when you talk about the
weed connect all that stuff yeah what's
you hand your average person who doesn't
play games a game controller and acted
like you handed him a flaming bag of dog
[ __ ] yeah I like what is this thing I do
with this how do I hope so from that
angle like putting something on your
face yeah that's a pretty big stretch
right and then the controllers and all
that stuff and getting out of it but
again I often say the juice is worth the
squeeze yep the end result is that good
that I think people will be willing to
do it once they see it cliff I love you
I love thank you for being so supportive
kind of funny coming by giving us a shot
hanging out with the rats most everybody
of course knows who you are follow on
Twitter get ready go to Bosque calm be a
fan make it ok much all right well we're
going to this trailer analysis for you